c'est quand même une mission la plus
gênante du monde et les sélections n'a
plus à mon avis la plus humiliante pour
les femmes je ne comprends pas que
aucune femme ne s'insurge face tout le
monde rêve de mettre à la place et
va demander bon miss monde vous auriez
vous aimé le faire
maintenant j'ai déjà repéré quelques
talons un parmi eux à d'accord qu'elle y
allait d'un gros coup de gueule alors
oui moi j'ai un coup de gueule parce que
j'ai réalisé l'hypocrisie profondes de
cette émission moi ça commence à me
saouler cette histoire de micro cette
histoire d'études cette histoire de
machin on leur demande juste d'être
belle quand elles vont défiler comme dit
matt à la foire de chez pas quoi on leur
demande pas quelle est leur cuit calais
pas du tout ça c'est la meilleure la
veille il faut que ce soit 6,2 de haut
niveau je veux dire à un moment donné il
ya une hypocrisie c'est insupportable
n'est arrêté de vouloir les faire parler
on leur demande d'être belle ça
s'appelle miss france et noël bat miss
intellectuelle et donc à ce moment là
dedans mais non parce que il ya une
bascule à chaque fois dans les bois
parfois celle qui était en tête ne pas
m'en faire une femme qui relie notre moi
j'aimerais faire une fille jolie belle
qui va être intelligente gentil et tout
ce que tu veux bien aux filles qui va
être cultivé comme ebel officielle s'est
désolé mais elles sont toutes choses et
de moi je dois faire une jaunisse ben
castle à l'arrêt alors méchaal est guéri
a raison et moi j'ai un truc qui met
franchement je trouve complètement nul
il ya un jury qui pour elle ne sert à
rien chaussez miss france on devrait
donner le vote à tous les français parce
que c'est ce qui se passe chez elle non
c'est 50 50 c'est 50 50 en deux ans à
près de 100% pour publier ses amis jury
puisque le public non mais alors excuse
moi d'abord un jury sur la beauté c'est
subjectif et moi rtl est partenaire
moi j'ai participé à l'élection de miss
sa voix je peux vous dire qu'ils ont
ouvert la bouche on s'est dit c'est pas
possible
le pouvoir entièrement au public et
savoir garder millions à voir et
honnêtement en plus et c'est de la
beauté c'est totalement subjectif de la
danse porte peut l'entendre du chant
pourquoi pas mais là qu'est ce qu'on a
elles vont faire des emplettes mais leur
avis qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout de leur
avis dans l'est
jouer moi je regarde je regarde mais je
pense que c'est le prime de jean pierre
foucault
et ce sans terre voilà ce qu'il a fait à
peine mieux france je vous jure faire un
aveu je vous parle je mettrai mon droit
qui le fait jamais mis dans mes amis
c'est le meilleur benson saiss et le
meilleur c'est formidable c'est la seule
c'est une merveille des merveilles mais
miss france je vois ça y est vous aussi
je suis d'accord avec vous j'en ai marre
en ce moment deux de ces émissions là je
sais pas là je trouve qu'en ce moment je
n'ai pas à ça c'est une hypocrisie sa
voix sa ronde tout est enregistré
bon là c'est mission c'est un diamant
lemon au marais dont je vous parle pas
que de miss monde en parle de tous et
c'est devenu chiant franchement je vous
dis axa de regarder je ne regarde plus
du tout la télé par les émanations sport
tas par les mails et les événements
sportifs je ne regarde plus est est
parce qu on se fait chier voilà je dis
la vérité on se fait ch il se passe rien
c'est une tannée